some survivors and those accused of
sexual misconduct on college campuses
say the title 9 system governing the
cases is not working title 9 was
originally enacted to ensure female
students were given equal access to
education the law was later expanded to
include sexual misconduct
although sexual harassment and assault
are crimes on campus these cases are
handled by title 9 investigations and
don't follow the same rules as Criminal
Court the new CBS n originals
documentary speaking frankly title 9
talked to both survivors and those
accused of sexual misconduct in this
clip two female students described what
happened when they reported their
assaults to the title nine offices at
their respective schools their
identities have been concealed due to
the sensitive nature of the cases
discussed I'm here today because my
sophomore year I was raped by a fellow
student athlete so two weeks into my
freshman year I was raped by another
student athletes I reported it to the
Dean of Students who was in charge of
title 9 reporting it and didn't really
help that all it kind of made matters
worse I feel like the process was more
harmful to me in a lot of ways than what
actually happened to me they told me I
couldn't go to the city police I had to
go to the on-campus police I didn't feel
like I was safe these which the title
nine coordinator in the middle of my
process I had to go I had to restart the
entire process so that was I meant
reinvesting it in everything and read
like opening everything up and they kept
reopening it but they didn't really tell
me why they were reopening it the
statements that I had written before
they all the times wrong the dates were
wrong they found him responsible twice
and he appealed it twice it seemed that
nothing was being resolved and there was
it was kind of stagnant because they
have the mutual no contact orders so
anyway that he was I couldn't be
anywhere that I was he couldn't be I
made it very difficult for me to go out
to go to school even which was the main
thing I don't think that justice was
served
they didn't even suspend him Wow Adam
Yamaguchi executive producer of CBS and
originals is here with us right now to
talk more about this documentary you
know how do colleges and universities
work with law enforcement in these cases
when you hear from people feeling as
though there was no justice with this
process you know surprisingly there
isn't a lot a whole lot of coordination
anyone who complains to campus has the
right to go to police but only about 20
percent do according to the Department
of Justice and that involves a
completely different criminal proceeding
we have to remember that title 9 was
essentially born out of the Civil Rights
Act of 64 right which did not apply sex
discrimination in schools and so we've
seen over the years in expansion of
title 9 as you mentioned it that was
expanded to include equal access to
sports and then the Supreme Court in the
90s ruled that sex assault sexual
assault constituted a barrier to equal
access to education so as the role of or
as the definition of sex discrimination
has expanded so too as the role of
college campuses let me ask you this the
documentary features male students who
say they were falsely accused and there
was no clear process is there no
standard policy there isn't I mean title
9 is a very short statute and it isn't
very clear and so campus coordinators
have largely had to figure out how to
implement the law or the spirit of the
law and so it's all over the place some
coordinators lean toward favoring the
accusers others favor the accused the
Department of Justice are started the
Department of Education is currently
reviewing the process but it isn't
entirely clear how or when those changes
will trickle down yes
frustrating for everybody absolutely all
right Adam Yamaguchi thank you very much
and you can strain this CBS and
originals documentary speaking frankly
title 9 on our website go to CBS
news.com slash title 9